- [Jon Sindreu] This is Boeing's 737,
and this is the Airbus A320.
They're by far the most
popular passenger planes
sold around the world
with over a fifth of them flying in China,
making it a key market.
- This is a continuation
of a long-term strategy
of Airbus in China.
- But these two rivals
may soon have a new direct competitor.
The C919 made by Chinese state-owned
aviation company Comac.
These planes are expected to enter
into service later this year
and state-owned airlines in China
have already ordered or expressed interest
in more than 1000 of them.
Comac is owned and heavily
subsidized by Beijing.
And that makes the company potentially
the biggest challenge to a duopoly
that has dominated the market
for over three decades.
- I'm looking forward to...
- [Jon Sindreu] The rise of
China's aviation industry
is one big reason why the
US and the European union
have called a truce on
a 17 year tariff fight
over government subsidies.
- Others are taking the opportunity
to launch their own industries.
And we have been too busy,
fighting each other to pay attention.
- So how can Airbus and
Boeing counter Comac.
Technology, their global reach
and growing political support
could be some of the answers.
Boeing and Airbus have been
rivals since the 1960s.
Back then, the European company was seen
as an overly subsidized laggard,
but after 1988, Airbus' A320
allowed it to knock Boeing off
the top spot several times.
So facing new competition,
Boeing nudged the US
to start a legal fight in 2004,
and then...
- The EU has today decided
to take the United States
to the World Trade Organization
over the massive subsidies
they gave to Boeing.
- [Jon Sindreu] It became the
longest and most costly battle
in the history of the
World Trade Organization.
Resulting in more than a
billion dollars in tariffs.
Lately, Airbus has pulled ahead of Boeing
in terms of orders.
That's also because Boeing
has been dealing with a major
crisis since the grounding
of its 737 Max planes,
After a string of crashes.
- All of us feel the immense
gravity of these events
across our company.
- The Corona virus pandemic has
also hit both companies hard
with both delivering
hundreds fewer planes,
but there's one market that
wasn't doing us badly, China.
At one point, China became
the world's largest aviation market.
As the US canceled flights.
- [Jon Sindreu] Now the US and Europe
have decided to suspend
their trade fight to work
together and focus on China.
- To confront the threat
from China's ambitions
to build an aircraft sector...
- [Jon Sindreu] Airbus told us
that Comac could take a share
of the single aisle market
by the end of the decade.
And in China, that direct competition
is about to start.
(foreign language)
- [Jon Sindreu] Since 2008,
Comac alone has received
between 49 and $72
billion in government aid,
according to industry watchers.
and has successfully built
a regional plane, the ARJ21.
The C919 has cost between 9 to $20 billion
to develop.
It's designed to directly compete
with narrow-body planes
like the 737 and the A320,
which can handle a range of
short and medium haul routes.
The Chinese aircraft
is less fuel efficient,
has a shorter range and lacks
the global service network
of the Western plane makers.
But China alone will
need some 8,600 planes
over the next 20 years,
according to Boeing.
- I believe their need for
aircraft is significant.
- And Comac wants to
provide many of those.
Orders for Western planes
from Chinese airlines
are much lower than what
demand would suggest
indicating that they may
plan to buy the C919 instead.
China and Russia are now
also developing the CR929.
A long haul wide-body aircraft
that should start being built this year.
(tech music)
So how could Airbus and
Boeing counter Comac?
Well, first there is manufacturing.
Boeing has been developing
planes for over a century
and relies on decades of experience
and intellectual property
to deploy the latest plane technology.
Comac is some 90 years
younger than Boeing.
And it's C919 has already
faced production delays.
It will initially only be able to produce
very few C919s each month.
Boeing and Airbus have
also used their duopoly
to create an international
network of parts, servicing
and mechanics to ensure their planes
can operate around the globe.
Even if Comac's planes
become successful in China,
they might be hard to export.
And then there is concessions.
Airbus has already
received around $13 billion
in pandemic bailout support,
which it is partly investing
into researching hydrogen planes.
- One particular technology pathway,
which we find most promising, is hydrogen.
- Boeing and Airbus's new found truce
could help them pose
legal challenges to Comac
while still trying to extract concessions
from their own governments
to develop new, cheaper
and more fuel-efficient planes.
Finally, there is the fact
that the C919 is built mostly on parts
made by Western suppliers.
Engines are the hardest
part of the plane to build.
And the C919 might still be a decade away
from flying on Chinese-made propulsion.
For now, it uses engines
made by General Electric and Safran.
The US and EU don't want
to hurt these companies,
but geopolitical tensions could
eventually reach them too.
China's already caught up with
the west in many industries
like trains, cars, and digital technology.
So the C919 may be a stepping stone
to posing a real challenge
in aerospace as well.
After all the country
can potentially instruct
it's state-owned airlines to buy
as many homemade planes as it desires.
(tech music continues)